d'abord je suis allée dans une clinique
où on dit mais on n'est pas là pour ça
allez donc dans un hôpital etc c'était
une maternité ça voulait dire nous on
est là pour les gens qui ont des enfants
on est là pour ceux qui les enfants
et en examinant il retire à une sorte de
petit caillot de sang qui me dit on est
très sec mais la grossesse est
interrompue alors moi j'en avais les
bras qui tombaient je dis ben enfin
évidemment il est sorti d'un air trading
avec l'infirmière on la regardant on a
l'air de dire cette pauvre fille
complètement
follementaire
ils m'ont fait aussi une piqûre entité
de la nuit que j'avais pas compris
pourquoi j'ai d'ailleurs demandé à
l'infirmière qui m'a dit c'est comme ça
on fait une piqûre et en fait ils ont
pensé que je mettais moi-même mis une
sonde ou quelque chose comme ça la
spécialement je me sentais rejetée
absolument
enfin que j'avais pas ma place là c'est
tout culpabiliser